[موسيقى]
كهوف الخفافيش
هي واحدة من أكثر الأماكن روعة
على وجه الأرض
عندما ترى الخفافيش تخرج من كهف ،
إنها حقًا عرض رائع للطبيعة ،
اسمي رودريغو ميديلين وأنا
أستاذ في الجامعة الوطنية المستقلة
في المكسيك لماذا  اتصلت
باتمان المكسيك ، فأنا أعمل على الخفافيش
والثدييات الأخرى التي أعمل عليها
منذ 40 عامًا ،
لذا في المرة الأولى التي أمسك فيها خفاشًا في
يدي عندما كان عمري 13 عامًا والتي
حسمت قدري حقًا ولم أنظر إلى الوراء أبدًا
حتى اليوم ،
تواجه الخفافيش الكثير من التهديدات ، معظم
التهديدات مدفوعة
بنقص المعرفة لدى الناس
ولأننا نخشى أن ينتهي بنا المطاف
بقتلهم كلما رأيناهم ،
هناك كهف مليء بالخفافيش ، يا مدخن
بالديناميت ، دمر المجثم
لسوء الحظ  لقد أثر ذلك على العديد
من أنواع الخفافيش حول العالم ، ولا
أعتقد أنني عملت بجد أكثر مما كنت عليه في
العامين الماضيين
للدفاع عن الخفافيش وحماية رجل المضرب إذا
كنت للأسف ستطمع ،
فسيكون ذلك من هيوما أخرى
لكونك لست على الإطلاق من
الفوائد التي نحصل عليها من الخفافيش ،
فهناك الكثير
على سبيل المثال ، كل مليون خفاش يدمر
10 أطنان من الحشرات كل ليلة
فقط تخيل ماذا سيحدث إذا
فقدنا تلك الخفافيش بين عشية وضحاها ، فإن
الحشرات ستستولي على محاصيلنا
وستمحو تمامًا  جميع أغذيتنا
العديد من النباتات ذات الأهمية البيئية أو
الاقتصادية للبشر أو للنظم البيئية التي يتم
تلقيحها بواسطة الخفافيش ، أحد الأنواع
التي لفتت انتباهي لمدة
أربعة عقود هو حمام الأنف الأقل طولًا
في أوائل الثمانينيات ، ووجدنا أن هذه
الأنواع قد تراجعت  بدأنا العمل بقسوة شديدة
مع المجتمعات المحلية ،
فقد أصبحوا مدافعين سيئين ،
بعد 25 عامًا ، كانت
هذه الأنواع هي أول حيوان ثديي يتم
حذفه من قائمة الريش المكسيكي
للأنواع المهددة بالانقراض ،
لكنهم أيضًا المسؤولون
عن تلقيح الأغاف عموديًا
الصبار والعديد من النباتات الأخرى وأنت تعرف
ما يأتي من agaves
tequila mezcal
لذلك بدأنا العمل مع التكيلا
الصناعة التي تثقيفهم حول
الأهمية المذهلة لحماية
الخفافيش ،
لذلك قرروا البدء في السماح
بنسبة معينة من الأغاف بالزهور
حتى تتغذى الخفافيش
عليها وتلقيحها وهم يعلمون أنهم
بحاجة إلى هذه الحمامات ،
فلا يوجد شيء مدهش أكثر من  عندما
أذهب إلى الميدان لأول مرة
مع مجموعة من الطلاب
وأعطيتهم خفاشًا لأول مرة وأرى
التوهج في أعينهم ، فقد حان الوقت لبدء
تمرير العصا إلى الجيل التالي ،
فأنا متفائل جدًا.  مستقبل
إيجابي للخفافيش وللعالم وما
أراه هو أن الناس مثل الخفافيش الآن
يدافعون عن الخفافيش وهذا
لن يرحل
ويمنح الخفافيش فائدة الشك
دعهم يسرقون قلبك
[موسيقى]